[موسيقى]
نريد تغيير الطريقة التي
تتعامل بها الموضة مع نفاياتها
[موسيقى] ،
اسمي جيسيكا شرايبر ، أنا
مؤسسة ومديرة فابسكراب
[الموسيقى]
وهي مؤسسة غير ربحية مقرها مدينة نيويورك
تعمل مع الموضة
صناعة التصميم الداخلي
وصناعات الترفيه
لاستعادة إعادة التوزيع وإعادة التدوير الزائدة
قبل بدء fabscrap عملت في
قسم الصرف الصحي في مدينة نيويورك ،
كنت أدير برنامج إعادة تدوير الملابس في المدينة خلال
السنوات الخمس التي أمضيتها ،
حيث بدأت الكثير من العلامات التجارية في
الوصول إليها  يسألون عما يمكنهم فعله
بكل نفاياتهم النسيجية
ولم يكن هناك حقًا مكان
يمكنه التعامل مع الحجم الهائل
لما يتم التخلص منه ، فنحن نعمل
مع حوالي 500 علامة تجارية في مدينة نيويورك
والتي تتراوح من
العلامات التجارية الكبرى المعروفة  مثل Express و J
Crew
إلى المزيد من الأزياء الراقية مثل أوسكار دي لا رينتا
كارولينا هيريرا
مارك جاكوبس ، ثم هناك بعض
العلامات التجارية المحلية في مدينة نيويورك مثل لافاييت 148
ومارا هوفمان وإيلين فيشر
كومباني  يتطلع الأشخاص الذين قاموا بالتسجيل للحصول على الخدمة
إلى
تقليل نفايات الأقمشة في كثير من الأحيان ، فإن
الأشخاص الأوائل الذين يتواصلون معنا
هم مصممين في شركة أزياء
ويشعرون ببعض الذنب حيال كمية
القماش التي يرمونها في
ساحات من القماش  عينات الملابس المصنوعة من
عينات القماش التي
نحصل عليها حوالي 8000 جنيه
أسبوعيًا إذا لم تكن قادمة إلى هنا ، فمن المحتمل
أن يتم طمرها أو حرقها
عندما تكون هناك شركة
مهتمة بالخدمة ويمكنها الاشتراك عبر الإنترنت
ثم نرسلها  أكياس الخردة الرائعة
يضعون جميع المنسوجات غير المرغوب فيها
في الأكياس ثم يطلبون الاستلام
بمجرد وصولها إلى هنا في بروكلين ، نوزنها
ثم يتم فرزها وفرزها
إما لإعادة الاستخدام
وإعادة البيع أو لإعادة التدوير
ونأخذ 12 إلى 20  000 رطل شهريًا
لشريك تمزيق في نيو جيرسي ،
تُستخدم كل هذه المواد في
حشو السجاد العازل لحشو
القطع الأكبر التي نعيد
توزيعها
ونوفرها لطلاب الموضة أو
لقد بدأنا العمل مع خردة fab في عام
2016.
لقد ساعدت fab scrap حقًا مارا هوفمان على أن
تصبح أكثر استدامة
لأنها ساعدتنا في التعامل مع
نفايات المنسوجات لدينا
في دار أزياء كل موسم
تختار مواد
مختلفة ستستخدمها في منزلك  المواسم القادمة
ويرسلون لك
عينات وهكذا يمكنك أن تتخيل
أننا نتلقى هذه الموسم
بعد موسم ، وتتراكم وتتراكم ، وقد
غمرنا حقًا فابسكراب نفايات المنسوجات هذا الذي
يوفر لنا هذا التقرير الذي
يمكننا رؤيته  كمية
النفايات التي
ننتجها ونستخدم هذا التقرير لتحديد أهدافنا
للعام المقبل ،
تم إنشاء خردة fab لحل مشكلة
أعتقد أن ما يثير
الذهن حقًا حول التواجد في
مستودع الخردة الجاهزة
هو كل هذا  النسيج هو فقط من
مكاتب التصميم
التي لا نتطرق إليها حيث يتم
إنتاج النسيج بالفعل ،
حيث تحدث العديد من العمليات الآن في
الخارج
لدرجة أن الكثير من النفايات يحدث أيضًا في
الخارج.
تتعامل الراب مع
عملية التصميم
في المقر الرئيسي للعلامة التجارية فقط ، فنحن
نحاول حقًا تحويل أكبر قدر ممكن
من مكب النفايات ،
وأعتقد أنه في السنوات الخمس المقبلة ، آمل
أن نبدأ في معالجة
مصدر النفايات
وليس فقط النفايات  نفسها
[موسيقى]